listen we knew this was gonna be an
award show like no other
but the pandemics took the virtual
insanity to a new level
records were set and there were plenty
of surprises so
let's go the emmy goes to
zendaya euphoria
zendaya jennifer aniston's jaw dropped
when you won she was cheering you on
how does that feel oh gosh it means uh
means so much to me i think
every single you know woman in that
category i obviously
admire immensely jen was thrilled for
zendaya but
if she needs a little consoling hi
anderson
hi pitt there's always brad yep the
oscar winner was up for a guest star
emmy on saturday
brad pitt is dr anthony fauci but lost
to eddie murphy
jen was on sighted staples sharing this
behind the scenes before going home
for a mini friends reunion look at this
corgi cox corki's there
of course i'm here we live together uh
yeah we've been roommates since 1994
jimmy
but i thought that was i had no idea is
it
is this live tv unbelievable
lisa kudrow you lived there too yeah
where else would i live
jen also shared a few emmy night secrets
her pre-show mask
hairdresser touch-ups and the after
party with her pups wearing pearls
clyde and sophie zendaya's win was a
well-deserved surprise
but in our book the 24 year old deserves
another award
best emmy reaction how are you because
you almost
fell off that chair when you heard your
name call
i'm doing well i'm doing pretty good
what does this moment mean to you
because you are now the youngest
woman to win in that lead actress
category oh it's
i mean beyond i i just i don't even know
how to describe how i feel right now
we've been there for zendaya's
incredible transformation
jet packing with her as a teenager and a
decade before her edgy role in euphoria
she was dancing and giggling in her
first et interview
back in 2010. i did hip hop dance
which was a lot of choreography when i
was about eight
now to another historic surprise shit's
creek
shit's creek it's great
a record-setting nine awards tonight
holy cow i mean to me it means that the
work that everybody has put in over six
years
has you know paid off royally
dan levy and his dad eugene also become
the first
father-son duo to win emmys in the same
year
daniel levy who took our
show and brilliantly guided it the best
thing
about it is i get to work with my boy
here which is absolutely great
and i was going to say there's a comfort
level in the communications
this was katherine o'hara's second emmy
her last was
38 years ago when she and eugene won as
writers on sctv does this mean that
there will be
some kind of return or maybe a movie we
went out on a good note
um and it would take a really freaking
good idea to top whatever just happened
check your inbox though because a couple
people here may have sent a few ideas
okay tbd we'll continue the conversation
i guess tomorrow
and where's the guy in the hazmat suit
who gave out all those awards did he
just come to canada
he came with a lot of awards up there it
was actually it was a
lady and she's still here
the poor hazmat suit just completely
fogged up and i watched her panic
before each award going out
just trying to like clear the hazmat
suit so that she could see her way
to the podium she probably just partied
with them all night
today we spoke with a hazmat guy
stationed at reese witherspoon's house
wearing one of 27 custom-made tuxedos
from this
costume designer it's like a plastic
feather as you can see
um and we just did the two-tone with the
shine to give you like the shawl
collar of the tuxedo we wanted everybody
to have a good laugh
you know if you won or you lost you got
to have a good giggle when they came and
win
no matter if you win or lose there's
someone outside
or in your home with an award so what
did carrie's face look like as you
walked away
this is chris hello chris hazmat suit
billy porter and rachel brazdahan didn't
win but invited theirs
in rami youssef simply got a goodbye way
from his